while it hasn't always been the case the
gaming industry has made strides in
representing transgender identities over
the past few years yet this sadly stands
at odd with the real world around us as
transphobia anti-trans legislation and
violence as well as vocal anti-trans
proponents has increased as such there
are still often stigmas misinformation
disinformation and common tropes that
trans representation can sometimes fall
into so we at Gamespot want to highlight
a few games that not only feature
transgender characters creators or
themes but also discuss what makes them
exemplars of how to integrate trans
characters that don't tokenize them or
use stereotypes
let's start with some games that
highlight transgender characters within
the game worlds themselves tell me why
prior to tell me why developer don't nod
had already garnered a positive
reputation within the lgbtq community
for its acclaimed queer focused game
life is strange despite some issues with
the game such as its focus on a barrier
gaze Trope in one of its two endings
which was directly confronted in the
game's excellent follow-up comic series
it was revelatory upon its release due
to a lack of lgbtq games from AAA
Publishers like Square Enix so it was no
surprise that don't not continued its
groundbreaking representation with the
Xbox published tell me why the first
game from a large publisher with a
transgender lead protagonist with
gameplay similar to its popular sister
series tell me why follows twins Tyler
and Allison Ronan who uncover a mystery
surrounding the death of their mother
several years earlier Tyler himself is
trans and the story allows him to feel
like a full character outside of his
trans identity yet also doesn't shy away
from how the small Alaskan town in which
the story is set reacts to his gender
identity either some in the trans
Community had critiqued the game's story
such as how Tyler's early life is
defined by sensationalized trauma
stemming from his trans identity which
is an overplayed Trope when it comes to
trans characters in media while this
Trope is often meant to be sympathetic
towards trans people for decades many
stories that focus on trans people have
only highlighted how trans people are
harmed because we are trans instead of
the joy that we get to experience by
being ourselves or just showing us
living our daily lives see movies like
Boys Don't Cry or the Danish girl for
well-known examples however while tummy
y does use this Trope it handles that
story with care and emotional depth
unseen in most other versions of the
story Tyler's relationship with his
mother and his trauma stemming from it
is given more Nuance as you unravel the
game's Mysteries what's more Tyler has
more relationships and sides to his
character besides just being trans or
facing trauma in fact the most
heartwarming moments of the game involve
Tyler developing a romantic relationship
with Michael if you choose to pursue it
the game itself is gorgeous and vibrant
filled with an intriguing mystery that
takes you on several twists and turns
throughout its three episodes tell me
why is a game that showcases that if you
write a trans character authentically
you can find a good balance between
discussing their transness while not
tokenizing pigeonholing or stereotyping
the character
The Last of Us Part Two despite the
character of Abby having garnered
transphobic backlash before the game's
release due to her non-traditionally
feminine appearance it was surprising
that the actual trans character within
the game was mostly left undiscussed Lev
played by Star Trek Discovery actor Ian
Alexander is in many ways a reflection
of Ellie from the first game with Abby
herself becoming Joel learning to find
empathy and Redemption through her
relationship with Lev and his sister Lev
himself was ostracized from his
seattle-based religious cult due to his
gender identity and was forced to fend
for himself setting him on a collision
course with Abby and eventually Ellie
herself it's through the character of
love that the game's themes are breaking
the cycle of Revenge and violence become
crystallized with Ellie Abby and Lev
themselves all working to find who they
are besides needing to seek violent
retribution on those who cause them that
hurt and harm while Love's main trauma
and whole story center around his trans
identity it does fit perfectly Within
The Bleak and despairing future of The
Last of Us franchise The Last of Us Part
2 uses Lev's trauma to tell a meaningful
story that allows Lev to have a complete
Arc while also featuring prominently in
the arcs of other characters in short
he's a full character unto himself but
also there to support others it's a hard
balance to find and The Last of Us Part
2 walks it with delicacy Apex Legends
while there is something to be said
about games that feature and centralized
stories about transgender characters
it's also worthwhile to just have
characters who happen to be trans within
the larger games context enter Apex
Legends which has both a trans woman and
a non-binary playable character as part
of its roster Bloodhound who is part of
the game's initial roster is known as
one of the greatest game hunters in the
frontier Catalyst who has added later to
the game was introduced as an Adept
witch who found herself involved in the
world of eco-terrorism both Bloodhound
and Catalyst are unique in that while
they're non-binary and trans identities
were part of their characters from their
Inception neither character's gender
identity has become the focus of their
character it's often easy to Market and
build minority characters off their
marginalized identity alone but
developer respawn made sure to make them
full people who just happen to be under
the trans and non-binary umbrella Apex
Legend showcases how casual
representation and inclusion as part of
a roster of larger characters can help
to normalize queer identities instead of
framing them as other by tokenizing them
even further while other games like
Borderlands 3 have added non-binary
characters in a similar World Apex
Legends has done it fast by having
Bloodhound themselves be a human being
ensuring non-binary people are seen as
humans who can exist rather than aliens
robots or creatures without gender that
they are sometimes relocated to in
fictional worlds and settings
transgender themes these are games that
may have transgender characters but more
importantly there's stories and style
reflect a transgender experience in a
unique way Celeste this 2D platformer
about a young girl climbing a mountain
forces you to continually fail over and
over and over again as you attempt to
clear increasingly difficult platforming
challenges in a vibrant world yet how
the gameplay mirrors the story of
handling anxiety and failure in the face
of a stressful World truly makes Celeste
feel meaningful Beyond its difficulty
and what led to it receiving widespread
Acclaim however what most missed in all
the Acclaim for the game was the reveal
that the main protagonist Madeline was
transgender while there are hints within
the game itself Madeleine's trans
identity is never focused on allowing
Madeline to feel like a full character
Beyond her gender identity Madeline's
trans identity was only confirmed in
2020 by The Game's writer and Creator
Maddie Thorson who herself is
transgender Thorson revealed that while
Madeline didn't start off as trans
Thorson soon found herself writing her
own struggles with her gender into the
character inspiring much of the game's
story aspects such as Madeline facing
off against a shadow version of herself
who is ultimately not overcome but
integrated into Madeline to become
stronger are not only universally
relatable but can also be viewed in a
whole new context given Madeline's trans
identity Celeste is a terrific example
of how transgender lives and experiences
are not completely foreign or
unrelatable to cisgender people anxiety
discovering one's identity and coming to
terms with yourself are Universal human
experiences just sometimes simply
expressed in terms of gender for
transgender people bloodborne PSX Elder
chore has always been a genre that many
lgbtq folks have found themselves drawn
to stories of monsters and hidden
knowledge that Society views as twisted
and madness-inducing take on a whole
different context for those whose basic
identities are sometimes viewed as
perversions by hateful groups in the
Video Game World there's perhaps no
better depiction of Eldritch Horror than
from software's bloodborne which in
encapsulates many of these themes and
it's despairing yet endlessly
fascinating world and it directly
confronts them this is why developer
Lilith Walther a trans woman resonated
with the game in an interview with
Gaming magazine Walther stated
bloodborne kind of talks about the
people in power and the protagonist is
an outsider and all your friends are
disabled people and sex workers and
other Outsiders then a lot of the
enemies are the upper class people
responsible for the plague who trapped
all the lower class people into Central
yharnam and closed the gates who then
die horrible deaths away from their own
Creations it's a direct response to a
lot of the problems with Gothic horror
as a genre it's incredible and it's
probably why it's so transgender
bloodborne even further is also
textually about women's bodies and how
they are often used and dehumanized by
violent worlds and the men within them
take the doll character for instance and
how Garmin introduces her to your Hunter
you're welcome to use whatever you find
the game also explores difficult topics
of sexual violence and how women's
bodies are controlled often through
things like reproductive Health which is
an experience that trans women don't
have directly but can resonate with in
terms of how our health care and bodies
are often controlled in similar ways and
trans men themselves in some non-binary
people do experience this directly so
while bloodborne fans are still
clamoring for a remaster or PC
re-release to update the game Walther
decided to take her love of bloodborne
in a different direction creating a
d-make version of the game that
reflected the original PlayStation's
Graphics the d-make is a loving
Recreation of the world of yharnam with
attention to details like lowering frame
rates for certain weapons and remodeling
the bosses it's also reflective of a
time when many young transgender
Millennials were first able to find a
community with other trans people in the
growing online World in many ways the
dmake makes bloodborne even scarier yet
truer to what makes it resonate with so
many bloodborne PSX showcases that the
themes of a work can resonate with a
trans experience even if it wasn't
directly intended to and allow trans
creators to express that bond with the
art in a way that goes beyond simple
trans character inclusion agency and
expression games have always been a way
for people to experience an identity
beyond their own part of the joy of
video games is to put yourself literally
into someone else's shoes and in many
ways that makes most video games
resonate with a trans experience yet one
of the most intriguing aspects of
expression for Trans people in games
comes from character creators character
creators have been a Hallmark of games
for years allowing players to create
whoever they wish in games but they have
a unique history with trans players who
often use character creators to explore
identities beyond their own many trans
people would play a game as their own
gender identity allowing them to be
themselves even if the real world
wouldn't games like Mass Effect are
often mentioned as touchstones in many
trans communities not just because you
could play as different genders but
because you could also form meaningful
relationships both platonic and romantic
with characters who saw you as your
gender and some other games even let you
explore accidental gender transitions
within the game's narratives like Saints
Row 2 allowing you to change gender
whenever you wish if only we lived in
that world yet these character creators
do have their limits for example many
character creators often Focus only on
binary identities leaving many
non-binary people or those who wish to
explore those identities unable to do so
even further while many games have
attempted to be inclusive of trans and
non-binary people they can at times fall
into mistakes or issues sometimes it's
baked Into The Narrative of the game for
example Call of Duty Black Ops Cold War
lets you choose to play as a non-binary
character however the game's story is
also one focused on you playing as a CIA
agent with a relationship with Ronald
Reagan in the 1980s President Reagan has
a very dark history when it comes to his
relationship to the lgbtq community due
in part to his administration's
mishandling of the 1980s AIDS crisis
that ravaged and traumatized the queer
and trans communities as well as his own
personal views and open mockery of lgbtq
people at the time so Call of Duty Black
Ops cold Wars anachronistic ability to
have Reagan respect non-binary CIA
agents feels at the very least rather
shallow and some may argue in poor taste
moving along though cyberpunk 2077 did a
decent job of allowing trans people to
feel included in its character creator
but also made some mistakes like
focusing on genitalia and tying a
character's gender identity to the
choice of voice selection this meant
that if a player wanted to have a deeper
voice they were forced to create a
character with a masculine gender
identity which seems to go against the
whole idea of being able to augment
yourself that a cyberpunk setting allows
ultimately these attempts seen in Call
of Duty and cyberpunk showcase a desire
to be inclusive by the developers but a
failure to fully wrestle with baked in
assumptions about gender or reveal a
lack of foresight for including trans
identities within the game's initial
design that the character creators are
trying to deal with after the fact for
example the way a game is coded
initially may make it difficult for
developers to try to go in and include
non-binary or trans identities later on
in the game's development cycle however
we spoke to the Sims 4 developers about
their initial difficulty with adding
non-binary identities to the game simply
because the coding of the game had not
been built for it from the ground up
it's been a challenge The Sims 4 is
about eight years old at this point the
franchise is going on 22 years old which
makes me very feel very old to say a lot
of work here was just uncovering all the
decisions that were made which sometimes
weren't obvious uh made very a very long
time ago but folks for whom gender
identity wasn't really top of mind and
I'm not faulting them it's just a
different set priorities at the time I
think one of like the really clear
examples to get into more technical in
terms is there's a flag in the game we
check to determine whether same things
happened which is uh is female or is
male and obviously if we want to go to
non-binary Sims on the road that's
probably not going to work so we had to
go back and retrofit that to you become
is gender and check for a variety of
keys as opposed to Justin's family's
meal so like that's just a small example
uh there's many cases like that uh and
it's all about building building the
foundation for when we do want to take
on the future that that again builds off
of that one game that managed to
sidestep these issues though was tiny
teen as Wonderland as they were able to
build a character creator from the
ground up with trans and non-binary
people in mind tiny teens Wonderland
lets you choose pronouns voice actor
hairstyle body type and more all
independently of each other it showcases
a more holistic approach to inclusion in
the game design and highlights how
different aspects of one's identity
don't have to align with each other
under a binary idea of a man or a woman
tiny teen as Wonderland has a thoughtful
character creator that underscores how
Society is beginning to understand the
distinction between things like gender
identity biological characteristics
gender expression and our ability to
manipulate all of these things and more
as with anything especially within the
lgbtq community it's an evolving
conversation but that's what games are
all about evolving growing learning
trying on new identities just as trans
people and every human being are always
evolving growing and learning about our
own identities and those are just some
of the many amazing games that are
pushing for not only trans
representation but how video games think
about gender and our relationship to it
video games allow us to create whole
worlds from scratch and thinking about
trans people showcases how we don't have
to recreate the same limited World Views
in our digital worlds and with that all
said have a happy rest of your pride
month